ce que j'ai fait pas au Premier ministre
c'est de l'état de la situation dans les
différentes provinces c'est de l'impact
de l'absence de l'omission de nommer des
juges dans un temps raisonnable c'est ça
que je lui ai dit pour qu'il réalise que
on peut pas continuer comme ça parce que
là ça maintenant ça avait un impact sur
et potentiellement sur la démocratie
parce que si ça amène par exemple des
arêtes procédures dans les dossiers de
violence par exemple la question
sexuelle violence conjugale les meurtres
les gens risquent de perdre confiance
dans le système de justice il faut
éviter ça
alors il faut éviter que la justice
perte de la confiance du public le juge
enchaîne la Cour suprême est en point de
presse ce matin rendez-vous annuel
depuis que les juges en chef pour faire
le bilan des travaux de la cour et cette
conférence de presse est fait c'est une
coïncidence
le lendemain de la démission du juge
Russell Brown suivant des allégations
pour lequel demain il y a jamais eu
d'accusation mais en pleine enquête du
Conseil de la magistrature le juge
choisi de partir de prendre sa retraite
et sa méfait en automatiquement à cette
enquête donc beaucoup de sujets à
aborder avec le plus en chef de la Cour
suprême le juge Wagner bonsoir puis
Emmanuel on va revenir au bilan dans un
extrait très important qu'on a entendu
de vous quand vous prenez la peine
d'écrire au Premier ministre et de dire
que c'est soutenable à situation
actuelle mais parlons quand même la
démission du jugement hier en pleine en
quête il a choisi de partir entre autres
parce que le système que vous-même vous
critiquez depuis des années quand à la
procédure de discipline des juges un
processus trop cher trop coûteux c'est
presque scandaleux au fond pour vous que
ce processus actuel que vous voulez
changer mais ça ça traîne au Parlement
dites-vous
précisé qu'évidemment dans le processus
disciplinaire des juges moi comme
jean-chef au Canada et président du
Conseil quasi à la magistrature je ne
suis pas impliqué alors jamais dans tous
les dossiers d'ailleurs que ce soit le
dossier du juge Brown ou n'importe quel
autre dossier je ne suis jamais appliqué
dans le déroulement du processus
disciplinaire cela dit vous avez
effectivement raison ça fait des années
que je plaide pour des modifications à
la Loi sur les juges pour rationaliser
le processus disciplinaire des juges qui
étaient beaucoup trop coûteux beaucoup
trop long les délais et qui a entraîné
des conséquences
indésirables il y a eu le dossier
Giroir entre autres la durée des années
provinciale des millions puis au moment
des destitués par le Conseil de la
magistrature du Québec à de démissionner
juste avant ce qui est arrivé
des millions pendant des années avec des
procédures d'appel etc et c'est vraiment
pas bon ça pour la crédibilité du
système vis-à-vis de public comment non
plus pour les juges qui sont de bonne
foi aussi puis ont besoin d'avoir une
décision rapidement alors donc j'ai
demandé ces modifications là j'étais
quand même heureux que le gouvernement
est amorcé les modifications en 2021 un
projet premier projet de loi SC5 qui a
passé par le Sénat finalement qui est
mort au Feuilleton c'est devenu S3 un
petit peu plus tard qui lui est devenu
et devenu C9 par la suite parce qu'il
repassé par la Chambre des communes le
projet a été adopté le projet de loi
modifiant le processus et la loi sur les
a été adoptée par la Chambre des
communes c'est monté au Sénat le Sénat
en fait deux modifications ou des
modifications et donc c'est retourné
maintenant à la Chambre des communes et
c'est encore là parce que je pense que
la justice aime pas les amendements
il est très conscient de nos besoins et
du dossier alors on espère que la loi
soit finalement adaptée alors très
concrètement la procédure à l'encon du
juge Brown c'était tout à huis clos ça
pour pas de transparence comme tel bien
que les journaux beaucoup couverts les
allégations ils risquaient semble-t-il
une audience peut-être publique
expliquer nous dans le fond qu'est-ce
qui serait différent avec votre projet
qu'est-ce qui arriverait si un juge une
telle situation sur qui pourrait
démissionner en prenant quête de faire
le dossier je pars à ma retraite une
retraite de juge sur plusieurs années
c'est beaucoup de sous je veux pas
parler du dossier du juge blanc comme
thème il y a des idées de démissionner
ça me fait ça m'a fait un dossier moi
j'ai été informé hier à 2 heures de
l'après-midi par une lettre du Conseil
Casal la magistrature qui m'a indiqué
que le dossier était maintenant clos et
qui me donnait une copie de l'adepte de
démission du jugement que j'avais pas
encore reçu alors là j'ai pris acte de
ça et on va regarder de la cour parce
que un poste vacant la cour vous avez
une session d'automne vous demandez au
Premier ministre de nommer leur
remplaçante le remplaçant rapidement le
juge le ministre la météo aujourd'hui
que c'était un poste bilingue c'est ce
que vous aimez aussi mais dans l'Ouest
canadien
une personnalité bilingue peut-être
issue de la diversité c'est tout un défi
automne alors on espère que ça va se
faire j'ai toutes les raisons de croire
que ça va se faire alors si le choix du
Premier ministre le profil l'origine du
juge en ce qui me concerne je pense que
là-dessus il s'entend avec moi c'est
peut-être quelqu'un qui puisse
s'exprimer dans les deux langues
officielles et ça veut dire parler et
écrire échanger officielle mais à part
ça il lui appartient décidé de
l'identité du ou de la juge en fait
dernier mot sur l'affaire Brown au fond
c'est qu'on il a beaupréter son
innocence à travers la voie de ses
avocats sur la place publique le premier
peut transparence comme vous l'auriez
souhaité pour éventuel cause
dans l'opinion publique
c'est le tribunal de l'opinion publique
qui veulent qui veulent juger
sont pas mal dans le domaine public
et donc je constate qu'il a maintenant
démissionné alors ça me fait aussi alors
merci d'avoir répondu à cette
question-là il reste que le remplacement
d'un juge de la Cour suprême c'est un
défi mais vous avez souligné à mettre
reprise en consommateur qui avait 80
postes vacants de tribunaux supérieurs
de réduction fédérale donc cours
supérieure et les cours d'appel vacants
au pays avec toutes les conséquences
puisque les c'est on doit respecter
votre arrêt de la course suprême la
redjordin qui limite à 30 mois les
causes criminelles puis Dieu aussi les
causes criminelles sont omniprésentes
devant les tribunaux
je pense que ça sert à rien de l'être là
mais suite à une réunion du Conseil
canadien de la magistrature au mois
d'avril les 42 juge en chef autour de la
table mon transmis le même message dans
leur jamais respectifs il y a des postes
qui sont vacants depuis des mois et ça
cause des normes problèmes parce que
évidemment il y a pas assez de juge pour
entendre toutes les causes il y a des
pressions de toutes sortes en matière
criminelles pour respecter les délais de
Jordan 3 mois pour les causes en cours
supérieur et donc et donc les jus
surtout va d'une part à faire des choix
décider quel dossier va passer avant les
autres ce qui devrait pas exister et les
dossiers en matière civile également
parce que eux vont être portés pour
faire de la place au dossier criminel
c'est sans parler de toutes les
questions des du stress additionnel qui
sont causés au juge à cause du Fardel
qui sont sur les épaules des autres qui
restent vous avez parlé de triages ce
matin quand vous avez fait la
comparaison avec les hôpitaux évidemment
quand quelqu'un manque de mourir puis
manque d'air il va passer rapidement
mais comment demander au juge de décider
quelle cause est plus importante
ça vous l'avez dit et dans la dans la
lettre envoyée au Premier ministre le
mais vous dites la situation actuelle
est intenable et je crains qu'elle ne
résulte en une crise pour notre système
de justice qui fait déjà face à de
multiples défis l'accès à la justice la
santé de nos institutions démocratiques
sont en périls et puis vous parlez de
l'inertie du gouvernement quant au poste
vacances il y a des milliers d'avocats
qui rêvent d'être juste pour la pension
monsieur le juge avec tout le respect
que je vous dois c'est la meilleure
raison
quand on dit juge pendant des années
remarqué vraiment avec respect je dis
quand même mais comment ça se fait
au Québec ici là encore supérieur de
juge en chef adjoint pas encore été
nommé et depuis le décès de l'arabe et
va pétrole malheureusement le 22 mars
alors on n'a pas du genre chef adjoint
dans un des district les plus occupés au
Canada alors la raison je ne sais pas
j'ai pris sur moi de donner suite aux
doléances de mes collègues jugent en
chef de tout le pays et on a convenu que
je l'avais écrit finalement au Premier
ministre notre dernière chance ultime de
provoquer des améliorations des
changements je l'ai fait ça je voulais
être une lettre privée
bon c'est devenu de ça a été finalement
publié éventuellement pas par mois mais
ça a été il y a quelqu'un qui a pris
connaissance de cette lettre là puis je
suis prêt à répondre du contenu c'était
l'objectif de alerter le Premier
ministre en disant écouté c'est sérieux
ce qui se passe et s'il vous plaît
prendre les mesures adéquates pour
remédier à la situation c'est pas la
seule cause des délais dans le domaine
de la justice il y a un financement
inadéquat de la part des provinces
également mais au moins on peut régler
une partie du problème en nommant les
juges lorsque les portes sont ça
réglerait au moins 80 postes parce qu'au
Québec on invoque les tribunaux qui sont
de la responsabilité québécoise on
invoque aussi la pénurie de greffiers et
d'autres personnels il y a même sacré
même des tensions entre la juge en chef
du Québec madame Rondeau et le conseil
de la magie et le ministre de la Justice
alors les relations avec les
gouvernements ça c'est c'est délicat
pour vous
faire faire attention et respecter la
séparation des pouvoirs mais reste quand
même qu'on fonctionne tous dans un même
but c'est d'assurer l'accès à la justice
alors tout le monde doit contribuer vous
avez dit ce matin je prends l'exemple de
l'Alberta parce que vous avez aussi dit
que c'est post vacances
la crédibilité de la justice je vous
cite ce matin vous avez dit en Alberta à
cet exemple 22% des affaires criminelles
avaient déjà dépassé le Jordan donc
Jordan ça veut dire l'arrêt faut mettre
quelqu'un qui se défend peut demander la
règlement
14 % de ces 22% porte sur des crimes
violents
puis l'envoient
de la crédibilité de la justice et de la
sécurité du public alors sans être à
l'armiste il faut quand même être
conscient là qui a un problème sérieux
et qui peut être résolué qui peut être
résolu
à court terme alors vous avez répondu
OUI il m'a appelé
suite à l'envoi de mallette et c'est ce
qui me rend un petit mixte sur constant
il y a trouvé évidemment
le propos sérieux assez pour prendre le
téléphone et m'appeler et me dire
qu'effectivement il y a la déployer les
efforts nécessaires pour d'une part
nommer les meilleures candidats
possibles et s'assurer également que ces
nominations se fasse dans un délai
raisonnable alors on va voir maintenant
mais moi je donne la chance au coureur
toujours et si le premier ministre me
donne prend la peine de m'appeler et de
me faire ces représentations là je les
prends parce que la fameuse arrête
Jordan on s'en est déjà parlé derrière
que vous aviez votre décision à la cour
était était minoritaire vous étiez
contre vous avez changé d'idées pourquoi
l'arrêt Jordan qui fait que ça 30 mois
est-il dans le fond important pour la
crédibilité du système de justice alors
juste pour vous dire dans la rue c'était
une décision de la Cour suprême 5 à 4
j'étais dans les quatre avec l'ancienne
juge en chef et je trouvais que le prix
à payer était assez sévère pour
pour déposer une telle décision
maintenant je me suis rallié c'est le
droit maintenant donc il faut se rallier
en vertu de la Loi du principe des
précédents et j'ai réalisé que dans les
faits cela a apporté beaucoup de choses
positives beaucoup de pression en tout
cas ça beaucoup de pression surtout tous
les acteurs du domaine les gouvernements
ont réalisé qu'il fallait qu'ils
investissent pas seulement dans des
palais de justice mais dans la
technologie
mais il reste encore beaucoup à faire et
c'est la raison pour laquelle Jordan est
important maintenant on ne peut pas
euh
mentionné que les problèmes sont à cause
de Jordan je pense que la société on
mérite comme société d'avoir un système
de justice qui puisse qu'il puisse
effectivement s'accommoder de Jordan à
l'autre mot un individu a le droit
d'avoir son procès criminel à
l'intérieur de 30 mois comment expliquer
puis je regardais vos chiffres également
que c'est une grande majorité des causes
sont de son de matières criminelle à la
Cour suprême ça cause la charte et
comment expliquer que c'est la majorité
des causes
dans les dernières années c'est sûr que
il y a beaucoup de il y a beaucoup de
dossiers criminels à cause de la Charte
des droits
mais il y a des appels de plein droit à
ce qu'on appelle également en matière
criminelle seulement c'est lorsqu'il y a
une dissidence au niveau de l'écoute
cour d'appel dans les différentes
provinces automatiquement il y a un
droit d'appel automatique
des décisions qui a des impacts sérieux
sur la vie la vie des gens en même temps
dans votre collection ce matin vous vous
faites allusion à vos rencontres avec
vos homologues à l'échelle
internationale puis j'ose vous poser la
question quand vous rencontrez vos
homologues américains
de quoi parlez-vous parlez-vous
d'indépendance judiciaire c'est une
cause que vous défendez beaucoup c'est
très éthique peut-être des principes
que je vous avais devoir une obligation
de réserve d'avoir de réserve mais j'ose
la question quand même
alors de quoi on va parler je sais pas
si vous saviez mais nous collègues
américains viennent au Canada en
septembre prochain alors je vous la
donne alors il y a une tradition quand
vous savez là il y a différentes avec
différentes courses suprême dans le
monde on a des échanges
intervalles plus ou moins réguliers là
c'est le tour des Américains à venir
nous voir puis il va venir à Montréal en
plus alors ma province natale alors j'ai
dit oui il y a le juge Roberts jusqu'à
gun jusqu'à
on va les rencontrer j'ai pas encore
identifié les sujets
en fait ça m'amène à vous poser la
question de si vous la course suprême du
Canada est-ce qu'elle doit dans ses
décisions refléter l'opinion publique
majoritaire ou c'est pas pertinent la
course décide selon les faits et le
droit applicable point à la ligne parce
qu'aux États-Unis c'est l'inverse la
Cour suprême actuellement
prends des décisions notamment sur
l'avortement alors que le
75% de la population est favorable à
l'avortement qui est très politisé
là-bas
c'est pas notre objectif c'est pas comme
ça qu'on devrait agir non plus mais ça
fait avancer la société il y a eu dans
la Morgane
dans les médicaments
sexe on a eu des décisions ce que
j'appellerais des décisions
progressistes historique qui je pense
bien servi la société mais c'est au
Canada ça avec notre système avec nos
mœurs avec notre manière de décider
également avec notre charte des droits
que d'autres pays n'ont pas alors il
faut appliquer les dispositions de la
Charte et on a une jurisprudence qui se
bâtit au fur et à mesure des décisions
alors moi je suis très très heureux
d'être au Canada ils n'ont pas être
ailleurs
je comprends très bien est-ce que le
choix de prochain juge la Cour suprême
je suis à la boucle avec le début doit
tenir compte d'un profil
j'ose pas dire qu'on définissait le juge
blanc comme quelqu'un d'assez
conservateur il avait été nommé par par
le gouvernement Harper
on reproche ici au ministre barrette à
Québec d'avoir nommé un ami comme juge
alors quelle garantie on a que le juge
qui va être le mieux ou la juge ça sera
pas parce que c'est un ami ou c'est pas
parce qu'un profil idéologique moi je
suis pas d'accord du tout à qualifier
les juges selon leur tendance politique
ou philosophiques on les juge c'est des
juges la cour de la Cour suprême d'où
qu'il vienne quand vient le temps de
décider un dossier au Canada en tout cas
on décide sur les faits et sur le droit
et j'y crois sincèrement vous avez des
juges là moi y compris qui ont été
nommés au courant de leur carrière par
différents partis politiques de
différentes tendances mais quand vient
le temps de décider c'est sur les faits
et le droit et j'y crois et je pense que
ça fait une distinction ça la société
ici du Québec du Canada par rapport à
d'autres pays mais il faut continuer à
travailler pour ça et c'est pour ça que
dans le fond vous nous dites ce matin
dans votre bilan qui a beaucoup de
décision unanime à la course
ça veut dire que s'il s'entendent pas
alors on sort jamais gagnant avec ce
genre de théorie là je pense que tout
dépendant des dossiers chaque juge donne
son opinion puis on est neuf on provient
de provinces différentes de culture
différente de véhicules différentes de
langues différentes et normal qu'on soit
pas toujours d'accord sur la même
interprétation d'une disposition de la
loi moi je trouve ça réconfortant si on
était tous d'accord tout le temps
surtout les deux décisions mais on sera
en Chine ou en Russie
est-ce que votre profil juridique et
votre passion pour la justice les
valeurs peuvent défendez bien du fait
que vous avez eu un père mais de la
justice
d'accompagner souvent au Père justice
d'ailleurs quand j'étais plus jeune
l'immeuble cormis à Montréal la cour
d'appel maintenant mais j'ai vu à
travers son parcours lors quelqu'un qui
a qui s'est consacré au devoir public ça
m'a toujours impressionné alors là merci
de votre confiance vous plaidez pour la
transparence et l'ouverture ben merci
d'avoir mis en pratique ce soir merci à
vous
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI